brexit had always meant disruption and
so - now coronavirus maybe you can fit
the pieces of the puzzle together so
they make a coherent whole upping the
rhetoric had a letter from chief
negotiator David Frost
he said we find it perplexing that the
EU is insisting on additional unbalanced
and unprecedented provisions in a range
of areas as a precondition for agreement
between us we find it hard to see what
makes the UK so unworthy of being
offered the kind of well precedented
Arrangements common place in modern
free-trade agreements Secretary of State
Michael Gove ministers making clear
who's to blame the EU essentially wants
us to obey the rules of their club even
there were no longer members and they
want the same access to our fishing
grounds as they currently enjoy while
restricting our access to their markets
it remains difficult to reach a mutually
beneficial agreement while the EU
maintains such an ideological approach
today was a linguistic escalation rather
than a change of stance
what matters is what comes next but many
in Whitehall expects something of a blow
up in the next six to eight weeks
possibly around the Northern Ireland
border Britain and Europe have signed a
deal but will Britain adhere to the
obligations in that to Europe
satisfaction if Britain and Europe can't
agree over Northern Ireland the EU has
said there'll be no trade deal and some
play at ISM sure we're prepared for all
options but I have to say I'm not
optimistic I'm still determined but I'm
not optimistic
piece by piece ministers are pursuing
their brexit gameplan but what will
winning feel like Sam Cote Sky News